you know et squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve une nouvelle fois sur heavy fin
sur heavy on n'est pas assuré sur son
corps mais bon voilà salut salut qu
salut tube on a ça commence aussi bien
qu'à des rares fois on peut le dire
comment tu t'appelles je m'appelle heavy
et toi on est surtout le cerveau
discrètement qu'est ce que tu as marre
elle vient faire dans cette histoire et
vie la dernière fois on a essayé de te
paie shoot en pense quoi tu n'as pas de
preuve alors évident trois vallées n'ai
vu je vais te montrer quelque chose
c'est quoi cette vidéo et bien c'est
quoi c'est quoi cette [ __ ] on lui
donne le lien direct ici même can you
tube pourquoi d'un coup tu parle anglais
par là il alla et l'opl taux d orly par
l and tony attaquant donc pas ma maison
pour à l'aéroport d'orly à anthony fois
les poils mobile qui elle s est vite une
faille sur beaucoup de sites se trouvant
que vous portables sim ce qui me
semblait ça veut rien dire quel est ton
film d'horreur préféré conjure hing les
dossiers de houara thunder un petit
remix et le remis d'une vidéo non belges
insistent pour fille préférée vite mon
film préféré d'inscription tu avais la
coupe de cheveux de leonardo dicaprio
nom est plein et tu crois que tu as
coupé mieux et vie des sorties en 2011
est à jamais changée
bon j'avoue je suis pas très bien placé
pour dire ça mais bon et ville du mois
tout de suite tu m'as trompée avec un
abonné suite à ma vidéo tout de suite
non mais c'est quoi cette blague quoi tu
fais des blagues que fait les grands
parents se suffit dit moi la vérité
celle ci est différente pour chaque
homme comme d'ailleurs battu tromper oui
ou non et vie tu es en quelle classe ce
n'est pas la question est quelle est la
question
t'es tu fais le motorisé parade abonnés
parce que je t'aime
ça ne répond pas à la question je me
prend de haut parce que tu me prends pas
même dans tes rêves
le seul moment où je te prends c'est pas
des rêves des faits wiwa et vie qui t'a
perverti et vie toi elle répond sur
n'importe quelle question il n'y a pas
de problème protection un pervers
françois hollande est utile illuminati
nom françois hollande et le président de
france mais est-il illuminati paul
crayon soya rbs pinquier ça fait cinq
fois ce qui est vrai pour l'anglais
arrête
lol bah arrête de me parler alors ok ça
l'ubaye d'un coup de bluff comme on fait
des fois qu'on drague une fille faux
semblants combrouze baissière réponse à
la figure et pourquoi rouge rigoler
hashtag faiblesse de l'homme c'est drôle
en effet côté rémois base'art doute
enflammer la sacem mais qui devient
frustré d'un coup parce que tu es dieu
oui que fais-tu je suis posé sur un
nuage
la bonne vielle
a pas aimé cette phrase et vie qui est
ton amoureux secret je ne suis pas
amoureuse s'est passé quelque chose
entre nous pourtant bon tu peux me faire
ça c'était si sensuelle entre nous en
couchant avec une femme
elle pousse plutôt à le prendre tel vélo
fausses comme ça à l'envi de toi tu as
envie de moi pas du tout et tu as envie
d'un abonné nous sommes je suis désolé
pour vous ben oui bah vous est dans le
même état que moi du coup rien comment
veux tu changes de langue comme ça tout
les fera j'en peux plus moi il nous rend
como estas senio l'itas puta soit payé
un petit mot qui se jetaient dans cette
fois j'ai pas compris
nightwing n'est pas une fille estas hong
lei ça veut dire tu es un homme f.tajan
super typhon l'espagnol ah oui tu caches
bientôt je vais vite tu était-il arrivé
les marines et vie dit nous la vérité
sur djombo je sais que tu as toujours je
sais que je sais que ce chat toujours
cacher quelque chose
je sais que je chope ça situe à dire je
suis amoureuse évident tu es amoureuse
de jumbo on apprend enfin trouvé deux
cas elle est amoureuse plus tard oui il
n'est pas des points tu viens de dire
est vie et je tu tournes amoureux plus
tard est terrifié jobs aura vérifié plus
tard la seule solution
vous le savez comme moi rêve vendredi 13
tu m'aimeras gpl ou de sortir avec ivy
en cachette médias ferment et algues
vertes il t'a ghoul
je te dise bonjour il n'y a pas de mal
non tu attends ta manière des beaux
jours c'est ferme ta gueule de
larmoiements à ce moment là je dis plus
haut tout le monde dit fils de chien ça
va j'ai ciseaux fred
oui je suis clean of rain or alors y at
il une de tes deux personnalités qui
même on arrête on a mal on assez tenté
de séduire devant calais cet amour caché
entre toiture bonne saison et pointe à
16 ans je bosse tape une ville qui a
huit fois sondage est fait mais bien
joué mon grand ami du nom tu penses quoi
de ma coupe de cheveux que je pense que
tu es une fille bluebell très bien non
c'est vrai tueur garçons mais bon voilà
hockey me crois pas que je prends mal
c'est pas vrai bingo choix je pense que
tu es gentil au c'est mignon c'est parce
que je t'aime je te vois 10 pour rien
quand même excuse moi on dit quoi ça me
gonflait à répondre n'importe quoi tu
attends quoi une petite claque sur le
pet ou rejettent un point bas sous la
halle à quoi oui aussi bas c'est bien
mais on fait quoi on colle nos têtes
comme ça on fait rien tu es le soleil de
ma vie avec toi à l'hiver semble être
l'été pour moi
je veux avoir des enfants avec toi mon
coeur ouais ça car au-delà marché oui
mais déjà il faut faire l'amour c est
celle qui provoque md elle veut des
enfants mais voilà c'est pas moi le
pervers marions-nous tout de suite
allons-y allons lier nos shows allons-y
alonso opus à la d'humour c'est papa
faisait l e mail mon amour non je t'aime
en l'amitié je t'aime pas barre toi
petit cône je retourne avec jumbo ton
amour secret car reste ventes de ton
mari beach l'agencé de la fin de cette
vidéo j'espère que ça vous a plu
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas les mecs
comme d'habitude c'était la seconde fois
pour parler à ivy et c'était 100 fois
pire que la première fois en tout cas
les filles je vous conseille vivement de
demander avis qu'est-ce qu'elle utilise
comme crazy d'amateurs tu utilises tu
comme crème hydratante demain c'est
fergie le jeu n'est pas de cours demain
pourquoi
voilà donc vous êtes dans votre
pharmacie la plus proche à vous acheter
ça mais ça vous regardez en tout cas ça
me fait vraiment plaisir vous êtes de
plus en plus nombreux et on s'amuse de
plus en plus j'ai l'impression en ce
moment fait aux funérailles c'est le
plaisir absolument sans entrer dans une
prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir regardé
kyoto bis
allez si tu vas faire tes yeux
grégoire le petit passage de miroir aux
cravates les arbitres